I'm curious why does immutile therapy have side effects if it's just supposed to boost your immune system.
Because that's not what immutile therapy does.
Kind of misleading.
So immutile therapy is a drug.
So I've done one.
Keep through to IVs.
Can it keep you awake?
I don't know about that.
Every drug has side effects.
Immutile therapy.
What immutile therapy does.
What we talk about immutile therapy.
We're talking about the medical definition of immutile therapy, which is a drug.
So one of the reasons why your body doesn't kill every cancer cell.
Is that your cancer cells are your own cells.
And your own cells will have a little receptor on it that attaches to a killer.
Cell a killer T cell to tell the killer T cell that hey, I'm self tissue.
Don't kill me.
And that's the way your body keeps your immune system from killing all your cells.
Because if you didn't have that, then your immune system would just be, you'd be dead.
Because you'd kill yourself.
Your immune system would kill you.
Well, somebody got the bright idea is hey, if we could create a drug that would actually block that receptor.
So it would fool your killer T cells.
And your killer T cells will kill self tissue that it will kill.
You know, the cancer.
Well, it makes sense to me.
Well, the problem is it's not specific to the cancer.
So it's not going to just attach to the receptors.
The cancer cells, it's going to attach to all the receptors.
So you are definitely going to get side effects from immutal therapy.
The number one side effect of immutal therapy is a is an autoimmune disease.
Because you're, you're, you're killing self tissue and you could actually create antibodies to that self tissue.
Now, understand you will always create antibodies to that self tissue.
So the, the, the kind of, you could end up with kind of a temporary autoimmune disease.
So you should have been told by your oncologist that if you're going to do immutal therapy, you can get anything.
Any disease disorder.
That ends in anitis.
So like colitis, that's inflammation of the colon.
So, you know, you can get myocarditis.
That's inflammation of the hearts, the heart.
You could get anything that's causing inflammation of the body because you're getting destruction of self tissue.
Hopefully to the cancer, but you could get it anywhere.
So this is a drug and it also has other side effects.
So you can Google the side effects of P truda.
And you'll see that maybe keeping you awake is one of the might over.
So I'm still on a feeding tube. Is there anything that can help with the inflammation and tightness in my throat.
So I can.
Or quickly recover with swallowing and working with a therapist speech, that's all it is to well, anything nutritionally that will decrease inflammation.
Is really your best bet.
Which we've described multiple times all the flavonoids, the curcumin, the resveratrol, the green tea extract, the as well, the white willow bark, the stinging nettles, the.
Corsitum, those are things that will decrease inflammation anywhere in the brain and the body any type of inflammation you have.
That's probably your first go to from your traditional step.